This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历了同样的事情。格雷，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手解决问题。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, after the love and the enthusiasm that I received for our psychology of fashion episode and our psychology of personal style episode, so many of you demanded an episode specifically on micro trends. So many of you in my DMs being like, that part of the podcast was great. Can you do
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理。今天，在收到大家对我们的“时尚心理学”和“个人风格心理学”那一集的喜爱和热情后，你们中的许多人要求专门做一集关于微趋势的内容。你们中的许多人在我的私信里说，播客的那部分很棒。你能做
a full episode on it? And I thought that this week, we would. Micro Trends have flooded our feeds recently. I just feel like the internet cannot go more than a few weeks without circulating like the new it fashion trend, the new it top, the new it print. And I also think nearly every single one of us at some stage has participated. I bought a lubbu last year. I have to admit it. I currently have a pair of office siren glasses that you guys are never going to see that are, they are incredibly impractical considering I actually wear glasses. And they are so small and they are so tiny and that is a discussion for a whole other time. The question really is, despite the fact that we know it's marketing, despite the fact that we know these trends,
一整集关于它的内容吗？我想这周我们可以。微趋势最近充斥着我们的信息流。我只是觉得互联网每隔几周不传播新的时尚趋势、新的热门上衣、新的热门印花就无法运转。而且我也认为我们几乎每个人在某个阶段都参与过。我去年买了一个Labubu。我必须承认。我目前有一副“办公室警报”眼镜，你们永远不会看到，考虑到我实际上戴眼镜，它们非常不实用。它们太小了，太微小了，那是另一个时候的话题。真正的问题是，尽管我们知道这是营销，尽管我们知道这些趋势，
aren't going to last more than a year, maybe a few months. Why do we participate in microtrends? Particularly in our 20s, what is the pool, what is the drive, especially when things do tend to be cheap and poorly made and, you know, break after a couple of words. Would you believe me if I told you it all came down to human psychology? I think you probably would, especially since this is a psychology podcast, but microchens especially, the way they influence human emotion and human behavior, that is why they are so hard to escape and so hard to kind of walk away from. So today we are going to break it all down from the role of dopamine to social contagion, our nervous system, frontal lobe development, identity politics. They all have some
不会持续超过一年，也许几个月。为什么我们要参与微趋势？特别是在我们20多岁的时候，动力是什么，驱动力是什么，尤其是当东西往往很便宜、做工粗糙，而且，你知道，穿几次就坏了的时候。如果我告诉你这一切都归结为人类心理学，你会相信我吗？我想你可能会，特别是因为这是一个心理学播客，但微趋势，特别是它们影响人类情感和行为的方式，这就是为什么它们如此难以逃避，如此难以摆脱。所以今天我们将从多巴胺的作用到社会传染、我们的神经系统、额叶发育、身份政治等方面来剖析这一切。它们都有一些
role to play in this as you will soon be aware. So if in the past year, the past couple of years, you found yourself suddenly wanting to buy animal prints or an impractical shoe or an impractical bag or trinket, this episode is hopefully going to give you some answers. And it's not going to shame you from buying those things if they bring you joy. It's just going to explain the psychology behind why you want to buy them. So without further ado, let's get into. the psychology of microtrends. To begin to really understand the emotions and the psychology behind all of this, let's start by talking about what a trend actually is and what a micro trend actually is within that space. So in general, when we traditionally refer to trends, we are
作用，你很快就会意识到。所以，如果过去一年、过去几年里，你发现自己突然想买动物纹、不实用的鞋子、不实用的包包或小饰品，这一集希望能给你一些答案。如果这些东西给你带来快乐，它不会羞辱你购买它们。它只是解释你想要购买它们背后的心理学。所以，事不宜迟，让我们进入微趋势的心理学。为了真正开始理解这一切背后的情感和心理学，让我们先谈谈什么是趋势，以及在这个空间内什么是微趋势。总的来说，当我们传统上提到趋势时，我们是
talking about a sustained change in preferences that represents, often represents, I should say, some larger social, political, aesthetic, technological shift or advancement in society. To qualify as a trend, something, whether it's a style, whether it's music, it needs to show direction, i.e. it's different on you from what we had before. It needs to show duration. So it's persisting over a meaningful period of time, whether that's a few weeks, months, or years. It needs to show scale as well. So basically, enough people are buying it, consuming it, making it so that it becomes a recognizable part of our broader social world. We can see that particularly, somebody was saying this to me the other day, with jeans and gene trends and how things have changed over the
在谈论偏好的持续变化，这通常代表，我应该说，某种更大的社会、政治、审美、技术转变或社会进步。要成为一种趋势，某样东西，无论是风格还是音乐，都需要显示出方向性，即它与我们之前拥有的不同。它需要显示出持续时间。所以它在一段有意义的时间内持续存在，无论是几周、几个月还是几年。它也需要显示出规模。所以基本上，足够多的人在购买它、消费它、制造它，使它成为我们更广泛社会世界中可识别的一部分。我们可以看到这一点，特别是在牛仔裤和牛仔裤趋势以及这些年来事物如何变化方面，有人前几天对我说了这一点。
years. So skinny jeans in the 90s and 2000s when like extreme thinness was really chic, flared jeans in the 70s and 80s when dance and music and grooving and moving. was like the big thing. Wide leg jeans in the past decade, which shows like a movement towards comfort and away from restriction. That's like a great example of how trends match what's going on in society. And the thing is they can last decades, like the active, casual, at leisure wear trend we're still seeing right now, that is a trend that is probably going to stay for a long time or women wearing pants. At some point that was a trend. Now it's just part of the culture. Now it's just a dominant way that we see fashion. So again, a few seasons or a few years or life-changing
所以90年代和2000年代的紧身牛仔裤，当时极度瘦削真的很时髦；70年代和80年代的喇叭牛仔裤，当时舞蹈、音乐、律动和运动是大事。过去十年的阔腿牛仔裤，这显示出一种向舒适、远离束缚的运动。这是一个很好的例子，说明趋势如何与社会正在发生的事情相匹配。问题是它们可以持续几十年，比如我们现在仍然看到的运动、休闲、休闲装趋势，那是一种可能会持续很长时间的趋势，或者女性穿裤子。在某个时候那是一种趋势。现在它只是文化的一部分。现在它只是我们看待时尚的一种主导方式。所以再说一次，几个季节或几年，或者改变生活
or throughout our entire lives, like all of those things can be trends. Unlike though, major trends which sizably push fashion in a new direction, like the women wearing pants thing or the, you know, athletic wearers clothes or casual clothes thing, micro trends are short-lived, they are niche, they are forgotten about very quickly, and they are overwhelmingly driven by social media. Like social media trends, you know, they inflate really fast as everyone wants to get on board and everybody wants to make money, everybody wants to be seen as cool, and then the next thing comes along and they get dropped very quickly. Micro trends like social media trends, only last as long as our attention does. And in this day and age, where we expect to be constantly
或者贯穿我们的一生，所有这些都可以是趋势。然而，与那些显著推动时尚向新方向发展的重大趋势不同，比如女性穿裤子或运动装或休闲装，微趋势是短暂的，它们是小众的，很快就会被遗忘，而且绝大多数是由社交媒体驱动的。就像社交媒体趋势，你知道，它们膨胀得非常快，因为每个人都想加入，每个人都想赚钱，每个人都想被视为酷，然后下一件事就来了，它们很快就被抛弃了。微趋势就像社交媒体趋势，只持续到我们的注意力消失为止。在这个时代，我们期望不断地
entertained, that is not very long. That is why the micro-trend has become so big over the past few years. Here is where the academia comes in. Researchers who study fashion psychology have found that the life cycle of any fashion trend that you can think of, whether it is cow print, skinny jeans, ballet flats, cottage core, whatever. Every trend can be divided into five stages. Introduction, rise, peak, decline, and obsolescence. Okay, so let's track this cycle for a second. Beginning with introduction, this is when a trend emerges, maybe from a runway, from a celebrity, from a cultural or grassroots style bloke core. This was a recent one that was inspired by like 90s British football culture that was then kind of,
被娱乐，那时间并不长。这就是为什么微趋势在过去几年变得如此之大。学术界的内容就在这里。研究时尚心理学的研究人员发现，你能想到的任何时尚趋势的生命周期，无论是奶牛纹、紧身牛仔裤、芭蕾平底鞋、田园风，无论是什么。每个趋势都可以分为五个阶段。引入、上升、高峰、衰退和过时。好的，让我们追踪这个周期一下。从引入开始，这是趋势出现的时候，也许来自秀场，来自名人，来自文化或草根风格的Bloke Core。这是一个最近的例子，灵感来自90年代的英国足球文化，然后被某种程度上，
have made more publicly accessible. Corp Corps, inspired by outdoor hikers and their expensive gear. Normally there is like an influential moment or an influential celebrity or something that people grab onto, that people suddenly become like anammed by. And the trend has always been there, albeit not trendy in the initial kind of group that created it. But suddenly it gets taken out of that small, microcosm or that small environment and made global, national, made kind of cultural.
变得更容易被公众接受。Corp Core，灵感来自户外徒步旅行者和他们昂贵的装备。通常有一个有影响力的时刻或一个有影响力的名人或人们抓住的东西，人们突然变得着迷。这种趋势一直存在，尽管在最初创造它的群体中并不时髦。但突然间，它被从那个小小的微观世界或那个小环境中拿出来，变得全球化、国家化，变得某种程度上文化化。
At this point, experimental people are testing it. Major retailers aren't yet willing to take a gamble on it. They aren't yet mass producing it because they're just still not sure if it's going to catch on. Then there becomes a rise period. At some stage, the trend gains visibility. It gains traction. This is when we start seeing paid promotions, stylists. more celebrities, influences kind of wearing it.
在这一点上，实验性的人正在测试它。大型零售商还不愿意冒险。他们还没有大规模生产它，因为他们仍然不确定它是否会流行起来。然后会出现一个上升期。在某个阶段，趋势获得了可见度。它获得了吸引力。这是我们开始看到付费推广、造型师的时候。更多的名人、网红开始穿它。
There's often, again, some spark moment, you know, often driven by something that's happening online or driven by like a trend conscious individual. And now we're at the point where it slowly trickled down from more experimental individuals into more and two more general consumers because main brand or, you know, widely accessible clothing brands have started to make it cheaper or make it in more variance. The peak is when the momentum is at its highest. Items are widely, widely available across many major retailers. It is being embraced by maybe a majority.
通常，再次强调，会有某种火花时刻，通常是由在线发生的事情或由具有趋势意识的个人驱动的。现在我们到了它从更具实验性的个人慢慢渗透到更多普通消费者的时候，因为主流品牌或广泛可及的服装品牌已经开始让它变得更便宜或制造更多变体。高峰是势头最强的时候。商品在许多大型零售商处广泛、广泛地可用。它可能被大多数人所接受。
The rise of Sambas back in 2022, 2022, 2023, this is a great example. This moment of a trend peaking can last. a while, but often it will quickly fade. And that's when we move into decline. After the peak, there does come a point of oversatuation, you know, it's not cool anymore because everybody's doing it. So celebrities move on, influences, stylists, the average person kind of starts to move on, maybe not the average person, but the person who always wants to be ahead of the, of the majority starts to move on. And the consumer kind of gets tired of it. They're kind of like, I've seen this before. So brands start to phase it out. They discount the remaining stock.
2022年、2023年Samba的兴起，这是一个很好的例子。这种趋势达到顶峰的时刻可以持续一段时间，但通常它会很快消退。这就是我们进入衰退的时候。在高峰之后，确实会出现一个过度饱和的点，你知道，它不再酷了，因为每个人都在做。所以名人们继续前进，网红、造型师、普通人开始继续前进，也许不是普通人，而是那些总是想领先于大多数人的人开始继续前进。消费者开始厌倦它。他们有点像，我以前见过这个。所以品牌开始逐步淘汰它。他们打折剩余库存。
The decline stage often for the case of microtrends really quickly follows the peak stage. As soon as you see that a trend is extremely widespread and popular, you can kind of guess it's going to start declining pretty soon because, yes, people want to be part of the in group, but they also don't want to be in the in group that everybody else is in. So if everybody is wearing it, they're kind of like, well, how am I? standing out. This is when we get to obsolescence. Nobody wants to wear it anymore. It's not considered current, but as is often, I think becoming more common, the trend may actually reappear again in a reinterpreted form, even years, decades down the line. So we still might
对于微趋势而言，衰退阶段通常在高峰阶段之后很快到来。一旦你看到一种趋势极其广泛和流行，你就可以猜到它很快就会开始衰退，因为，是的，人们想成为圈内人的一部分，但他们也不想成为每个人都在其中的圈内人。所以如果每个人都在穿它，他们会想，好吧，我怎么脱颖而出？这就是我们达到过时的时候。没有人想再穿它了。它不再被认为是当前的，但正如我认为变得越来越普遍的那样，这种趋势实际上可能会以重新诠释的形式再次出现，甚至在几年、几十年后。所以我们仍然可能
see the bubble come up again. And also, the people who were originally authentically wearing these items because they weren't a trend to them, they are also going to keep wearing them. You know, they're going to keep participating. Because again, it was never about looking cool or fitting in. They just liked the item. You know, your dad still buys his new balance 530s, right? Whether the fashion girl is wearing them or not. So there is still this core, this core loyal group of people who have won this trend before
看到泡沫再次出现。而且，那些最初真实地穿着这些物品的人，因为对他们来说这不是一种趋势，他们也会继续穿着它们。你知道，他们会继续参与。因为再说一次，这从来不是为了看起来酷或融入。他们只是喜欢这个物品。你知道，你爸爸仍然买他的New Balance 530，对吧？无论时尚女孩是否穿着它们。所以仍然有这个核心，这个核心忠诚的群体，他们以前穿过这种趋势
and will continue to wear it afterwards. Again, think about any trend you can imagine. Almost every single one of them will follow the same five-stage pattern. The thing is, though, most trends nowadays, like in the past, the pattern and the cycle used to take five, 10, 15 years. Social media, fast fashion, has drastically condensed this timeline, meaning the gap between introduction and overhauling. oversaturation could literally be a few months, like with Labuboos, for example. Something could start trending on Monday. Like this coming Monday, a new trend could pop up.
并且之后会继续穿它。再说一次，想想你能想象到的任何趋势。几乎每一个都会遵循同样的五个阶段模式。问题是，现在大多数趋势，就像过去一样，模式和周期曾经需要5、10、15年。社交媒体、快时尚极大地压缩了这个时间线，意味着引入和过度饱和之间的差距可能仅仅是几个月，比如Labubu。某样东西可能在周一流行起来。就像下周一，一个新的趋势可能会突然出现。
By Friday, Amazon, Sheehan, Zara could be shipping out the first prototypes of that trend, because that's how fast they operate these days. That means, you know, what's cool can never really be cool for too long, because part of what makes trends last is the aura of inaccessibility and originality. But because everything is accessible these days, trends, again, are condensed. Honestly, whilst I was researching this episode, I was looking into companies like Sheen and like Amazon and like Al-Zaras. And the stuff that I found like blew my mind. I honestly thought that I was pretty informed about fast fashion. but the scale of these companies and their production and their output is just like off the charts.
到周五，亚马逊、Shein、Zara可能已经在运送该趋势的第一批原型了，因为这就是他们现在运作的速度。这意味着，你知道，酷的东西永远不可能酷太久，因为让趋势持续的一部分是不可及性和原创性的光环。但因为现在一切都是可及的，趋势，再说一次，被压缩了。老实说，当我在研究这一集时，我正在调查像Shein、亚马逊和Zara这样的公司。我发现的东西让我大吃一惊。我老实说以为我对快时尚相当了解，但这些公司的规模以及它们的生产和产出简直是离谱。
It's almost unbelievable. Companies like these have perfected the production model and the pipeline to production because everything is done in one factory these days. Everything from research to design to fabric production to garment production to shipping all comes out of one big industrial complex. meaning, again, something could trend. They could have a product that replicates that trend within 48 hours and they can make it even cheaper in the next 48 hours and ship it out
这几乎令人难以置信。像这样的公司已经完善了生产模式和生产管道，因为现在一切都在一个工厂里完成。从研究到设计到面料生产到服装生产到运输，一切都来自一个大型工业综合体。意味着，再说一次，某样东西流行起来。他们可以在48小时内拥有一个复制该趋势的产品，并且他们可以在接下来的48小时内让它变得更便宜并运送出去
because that's their business model. Their business model focuses on quantity and replication rather than quality. According to data collected by this nonprofit called Rest of World, between July and December of 2021, Sheehan alone added anywhere between, and I need you to be prepared for this. Are you ready? 2,000 and 10,000 new styles to its app every single day. Day, every day. Anything that trends, regardless of intellectual property, regardless of material, they can make a dupe,
因为那是他们的商业模式。他们的商业模式专注于数量和复制，而不是质量。根据非营利组织Rest of World收集的数据，在2021年7月至12月期间，仅Shein每天就在其应用程序上增加了2,000到10,000种新样式。每天，每一天。任何流行的东西，无论知识产权如何，无论材料如何，他们都可以制造仿制品，
and they can advertise the dupe, before they even have the resources to make it, because that's a way of them gauging interest. They have an entire market research team, an entire data team that tracks what is selling online for other companies and then compares that against their own sale data to determine what items are going to be hits, what items are going to be misses,
并且他们可以在甚至没有资源制造它之前就宣传这个仿制品，因为这是他们衡量兴趣的一种方式。他们拥有整个市场研究团队，整个数据团队，跟踪其他公司在网上销售什么，然后将其与他们自己的销售数据进行比较，以确定哪些商品会成为热门，哪些商品会成为失败，
what they should plan for, what they should create. So basically they can create an order inventory virtually on demand. It's easy to see how microtrends fit into this, right? I feel like I don't need to go into it any further, but I think it's really important to see the system that is like happening below the surface of our everyday consumer choices. So that's like, that's what's going on globally in in terms of the market. What is going on in terms of our minds? When trends are rising, peaking, falling. Why do we feel pulled into this cycle? At first glance, it might look really random.
他们应该计划什么，他们应该创造什么。所以基本上他们可以虚拟地按需创建订单库存。很容易看出微趋势如何适应这一点，对吧？我觉得我不需要再深入探讨了，但我认为看到我们日常消费选择表面下正在发生的系统真的很重要。所以这就是全球市场方面正在发生的事情。在我们的思想方面正在发生什么？当趋势上升、达到顶峰、下降时。为什么我们感到被卷入这个周期？乍一看，它看起来真的很随机。
Maybe it looks like a big coincidence, but in reality, there is a major undercurrent of human psychology at play. Behind every trend lies the psychological concept of social proof. And this is the idea that essentially, in everything we do, we look to others to guide our behavior, especially when we are not sure. Trends, trends give us a shorthand, mental and emotional code for what is going to give us acceptance. And again, what will give us access to the in-group of the time or the people, what will give us access to the people who we desire to be more like or we desire to surround ourselves with? If the cool girls are wearing baggy jeans, your mind says, well, if I wear baggy jeans, I will be a cool girl. I will have the uniform of a cool girl. It makes that mental shortcut.
也许它看起来像一个巨大的巧合，但实际上，人类心理学的一个主要暗流在起作用。在每一个趋势背后都隐藏着社会认同的心理概念。这基本上是这样一个想法，即在我们所做的一切中，我们寻求他人来指导我们的行为，特别是当我们不确定时。趋势，趋势为我们提供了关于什么会给我们带来接受的简写、心理和情感代码。再说一次，什么会给我们进入当时的圈内人的机会，或者什么会给我们进入我们渴望变得更像的人或我们渴望围绕自己的人的机会？如果酷女孩穿着宽松的牛仔裤，你的大脑会说，好吧，如果我穿宽松的牛仔裤，我就会成为一个酷女孩。我将拥有酷女孩的制服。它制造了那个心理捷径。
That is why so many trends are driven by celebrities, influences, people we see online, because why would we follow these people in the first place if a small part of us didn't want to be like them? Or if some small part of us didn't feel some kind of allegiance to these individuals. It's extremely compelling. And when you are bombarded with potentially dozens of examples of people following the trend every single day, the pressure to conform becomes a lot stronger. So, so strong, so powerful. Let's break this down a little bit further. There are actually a few distinct psychological processes that are going on at this very point in your mind that determine whether you are going to adopt the next trend you see on your timeline or not.
这就是为什么这么多趋势是由名人、网红、我们在网上看到的人驱动的，因为如果我们的内心深处不想变得像他们一样，我们为什么要关注这些人呢？或者如果我们的内心深处没有对这些人感到某种忠诚。这非常有说服力。当你每天被数十个跟随趋势的人的例子轰炸时，从众的压力会变得大得多。如此强烈，如此强大。让我们进一步剖析这一点。实际上，在你的大脑中，在这一点上，有几个独特的心理过程在进行，决定了你是否会采用你在时间线上看到的下一个趋势。
The first is how susceptible you are to something that we call social contagion. So basically, if you are closer to somebody, and not just physically, but if you are closer to somebody in terms of age, in terms of whether you admire them or not, your proximity is going to determine whether you pick up the trend. So basically, social contagion is this like rapid, unconscious spread of emotions, spread of behaviors, spread of beliefs that kind of ripples through a group or network. The way trends spread is often described as functioning kind of like an
第一个是你对我们称之为社会传染的东西有多容易受到影响。所以基本上，如果你与某人更亲近，不仅仅是身体上，而且如果你在年龄方面、在你是否钦佩他们方面与某人更亲近，你的接近程度将决定你是否会接受这种趋势。所以基本上，社会传染是这种情感、行为、信仰的快速、无意识的传播，在群体或网络中涟漪。趋势传播的方式通常被描述为像一种
infectious disease, you know, passing between individual to individual. One person adopts a trend, then the three people closest to them adopt the trend, then the people who follow them online, adopt the trend. It's literally like, it's like an airborne virus. You are more susceptible. You are more susceptible to social contagion, the closer you are to the source. Again, not just physically, but emotionally. Like, the more you feel a sense of similarity or allegiance to the person who is an initial adopter of a trend, the more you are going to buy into it. Also something to note, you know, the more a trend spreads as well, the more it mutates like a virus. And the more it becomes more popular to broader groups of people because companies know that
传染病，在个人与个人之间传递。一个人采用了一种趋势，然后与他们最亲近的三个人采用了这种趋势，然后在线关注他们的人采用了这种趋势。这简直就像，就像一种空气传播的病毒。你越接近源头，你就越容易受到社会传染的影响。再说一次，不仅仅是身体上，还有情感上。就像，你对趋势的最初采用者感到越强烈的相似感或忠诚感，你就越会买账。还要注意，你知道，一种趋势传播得越多，它像病毒一样变异得也越多。而且它对更广泛的人群变得越流行，因为公司知道
if they want to make money, they have to adapt a trend to more and more social groups. They have to initiate buy-in from more and more distinct subgenres. So they make it available in new countries, they make it available in new colorways, until it reaches like the highest status a trend can reach, which is that it becomes a must-have. The ultimate goal of a brand is essentially to be able to access all different subgroups of society through social contagion by providing a version everyone can relate to. I feel like the Adidas Sambas are a great example of how efficiently Adidas was able to do this. If you think about the Sambas or the gazelles or whatever they were, like, by their peak,
如果他们想赚钱，他们必须使趋势适应越来越多的社会群体。他们必须从越来越多的独特子类型中发起买入。所以他们让它在新的国家可用，他们让它在新的配色中可用，直到它达到一种趋势所能达到的最高地位，那就是它成为必备品。品牌的目标本质上是通过提供每个人都能联系起来的版本，通过社会传染来访问社会的所有不同子群体。我觉得阿迪达斯Samba是一个很好的例子，说明阿迪达斯能够多么有效地做到这一点。如果你想到Samba或Gazelle或无论它们是什么，在它们的高峰期，
I swear they were in every color, every type of style, there were bows, there were chains attached to them, there were different fabrics. This is a prime example of how marketers use social contagion to their advantage to make the virus, of a micro trend, I guess more infectious to as many people as possible. Next, during this process, we are of course also feeling the pull of social conformity. This is a process whereby we align our attitudes, our beliefs, our behaviors to fit in to the social majority or the people that we see as the social majority. And by doing that reducing uncertainty, our fear of missing out combined with the illusion of scarcity.
我发誓它们有各种颜色，各种风格，有蝴蝶结，有链子，有不同的面料。这是营销人员如何利用社会传染来发挥他们的优势，使微趋势的病毒对尽可能多的人更具传染性的一个主要例子。接下来，在这个过程中，我们当然也感受到了社会从众的拉力。这是一个过程，通过这个过程，我们调整我们的态度、信仰、行为以融入社会大多数人或我们视为社会大多数人的人。并通过这样做减少不确定性，我们对错失恐惧症的恐惧与稀缺性的错觉相结合。
So things like limited item drops, limited time to bag a trend before saturation hits, means that we are so bought in to seeing trends as a form of social currency. We are so brought into feeling like, if I buy this item, I'm going to be accepted. And if I don't, there is this real emotional drop of like, I don't know, like social rejection. Don't feel worried or ashamed if you've done this. We all have.
所以像限量商品投放、在饱和之前抢购趋势的有限时间，意味着我们非常买账将趋势视为一种社会货币。我们非常买账感觉像，如果我买了这个商品，我就会被接受。如果我不买，就会有一种真正的社会拒绝的情感落差。如果你这样做过，不要感到担心或羞耻。我们都做过。
And we all will probably continue to do so because it is hardwired in you to want to conform and to always want to be close to the thing that is most accepted or most popular in society. There was a 2015 study from researchers at Stanford and also researchers in the Netherlands, actually, it was a collaboration. And it basically showed the primal neurological reactions we have. have when conforming. It, like conforming, whether it's through fashion, through music, through behavior, is a incredibly addictive and powerful form of positive reinforcement learning. And it initiates all kinds of like positive emotions and happy emotions that make us want to continue
而且我们可能都会继续这样做，因为想要从众并总是想接近社会中最被接受或最流行的东西是你的天性。2015年斯坦福大学和荷兰研究人员的一项研究，实际上，这是一次合作。它基本上展示了我们在从众时所拥有的原始神经反应。它，像从众，无论是通过时尚、音乐还是行为，是一种令人难以置信的令人上瘾和强大的正强化学习形式。它引发了各种各样的积极情绪和快乐情绪，使我们想要继续
doing so. So that is the first explanation for the like proliferation of micro trends. It's all social. It's all about wanting to belong. There is also a biological lens to this as well. Believe it or not, what you buy is often ruled by the tiniest chemicals inside your brain, which we are going to explore together after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
这样做。所以这就是微趋势激增的第一个解释。这全是社会的。这全是关于想要归属感。这也有一个生物学视角。信不信由你，你买的东西通常由你大脑中最微小的化学物质统治，我们将在短暂休息后一起探索。和我们在一起。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康和健身专家以及更多人交谈，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app,
去超越统治健康产业的不切实际和过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是炎症性的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到害怕的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是2%在I-Hart电台应用程序，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
Apple Podcasts，或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我整天都愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上也有艾滋病，所以。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
谢谢你完成那句话。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you
我在谈论。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候做得够多了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现做一个好人很重要，当你
hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
在地球上。你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对。那是两种不同的信任水平。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾。这开始了一场长达数年的法庭斗争来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历了同样的事情。格雷，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never. mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们，先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新
season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. own hands. I said, oh, hell no, I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Whilst the desire for social acceptance definitely drives us towards micro-trans, right? There is another big driver at play, and that is dopamine culture. dopamine culture, the rush that we get when we browse, when we click, when we buy, when we have our purchase, you know, turn up at our door.
一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎不在乎。所以她们决定自己动手解决问题。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的报应。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。虽然对社会接受的渴望确实驱使我们走向微趋势，对吧？还有另一个巨大的驱动力在起作用，那就是多巴胺文化。多巴胺文化，当我们浏览、点击、购买、当我们的购买出现在门口时，我们得到的快感。
It feels like a sense of approval and it activates something really ancient and primal in us. That is the desire to hunt, to gather, to receive, to basically like feel proud of our capture, feel proud of our resource. microtrends activate dopamine in so many ways through novelty, through this anticipation cycle, because there's always going to be something better or newer for us to wear, through just the act of spending money. Spending money gives us dopamine. A lot of it also comes down to our attention and the use of shopping as entertainment. Our attention, you know, especially in the context of microtrendes, is kind of.
它感觉像是一种认可，它激活了我们内心非常古老和原始的东西。那就是狩猎、采集、接收的欲望，基本上就是为我们的捕获感到自豪，为我们的资源感到自豪。微趋势通过新奇感、通过这种预期周期激活多巴胺，因为总会有更好或更新的东西供我们穿，通过仅仅是花钱的行为。花钱给我们多巴胺。很多也归结为我们的注意力和将购物作为娱乐的使用。我们的注意力，你知道，特别是在微趋势的背景下，是某种。
What catches your attention online in the real world is what releases dopamine. When something no longer captures our attention, the dopamine levels drop. We go searching for our next hit. Over time, it can, and it does create an addictive feedback loop that fuels microtrends because we are looking for something to basically keep us entertained and excited at all times. our brain wants that so badly. It is hungering for it. Micro trends as well represent something more than just clothes, right? Scrolling your feed for the next thing, buying an outfit, trying it on days later is a form of short-term entertainment and gratification. It is all part of a scientifically
在网上和现实世界中吸引你注意力的是释放多巴胺的东西。当某样东西不再吸引我们的注意力时，多巴胺水平就会下降。我们去寻找我们的下一次快感。随着时间的推移，它确实创造了一个令人上瘾的反馈循环，助长了微趋势，因为我们正在寻找某种东西来基本上让我们时刻保持娱乐和兴奋。我们的大脑非常渴望它。它渴望它。微趋势也代表了不仅仅是衣服，对吧？滚动你的信息流寻找下一件事，买一套衣服，几天后试穿，这是一种短期娱乐和满足感。这一切都是科学的一部分
engineered dopamine feedback loop that wants you to, wants you to prioritize being happy fast, and wants you to prioritize getting what you want quickly over long-term gratification. This is a much broader societal shift, as I'm sure a lot of you guys are thinking. We can see this pattern everywhere, literally everywhere. Instead of reading a newspaper, you know, we watch a 30-second hot take online. Instead of consuming two hours of poetry or stand-up comedy, we watch one viral moment. Instead of listening to an album, we enjoy the snippet of one song on TikTok. Everything needs to provide instant gratification as quickly as possible.
设计的微趋势多巴胺反馈循环，想要你，想要你优先考虑快速快乐，并想要你优先考虑快速得到你想要的，而不是长期满足。这是一个更广泛的社会转变，我相信你们很多人都在想。我们可以到处看到这种模式，字面上到处都是。而不是读报纸，你知道，我们在网上看30秒的热评。而不是消费两个小时的诗歌或单口喜剧，我们看一个病毒式时刻。而不是听一张专辑，我们在TikTok上享受一首歌的片段。一切都需要尽可能快地提供即时满足。
And microtrans again are no different. Instead of buying clothes less often, instead of developing a unique sense of style, instead of really like hunting for quality pieces, instead of literally making our clothes. Right. Now, this is just another form of quick entertainment for us to consume. What's more, I think brands know this. They definitely know this. One study called an economic perspective on attention or something like that. This study basically suggests that because there is so much online that we can consume, our attention is now a really valuable resource. And so to capture it, brands, companies, people, influencers now understand that that requires something really unique. In other words, like, we are less able to focus on one thing at a time or for a sustained amount of time. So you have to resort to something even more outlandish and even more attention-grabbing to bring people into the trend. And you really, like brands really want to push things to go viral so that longevity is no longer the goal.
微趋势也是如此。我们不再是减少购买衣服的频率，不再是培养独特的个人风格，不再是真正去搜寻高品质的单品，甚至不再是亲手制作衣服。没错，现在这只是我们消费的一种快速娱乐形式。而且，我认为品牌方深知这一点。他们绝对清楚。有一项名为《注意力的经济视角》之类的研究指出，正是因为网上有太多东西可供消费，我们的注意力现在成了极其宝贵的资源。因此，为了抓住它，品牌、公司、个人和网红们现在都明白，这需要一些真正独特的东西。换句话说，我们越来越难以一次专注于一件事，或者长时间保持专注。所以你必须诉诸更古怪、更吸引眼球的东西来吸引人们加入潮流。品牌真的非常希望推动事物病毒式传播，以至于长久性不再是目标。
It's why they're always looking for like the hottest new celebrity to face up their campaigns, always looking for like a real kind of gotcha moment or a big brand campaign that's just going to give them as much attention and eyes on their product as possible. Trends are nothing without that. The other thing that brands do that elevates our desire to buy micro trends is they make the shopping process really stressful to push us towards a purchase. So basically they make it so that everything feels like it's going to be urgent, the product is going to run out, the product's no longer going to be on sale, so that we buy it fast and we get the sense of relief that like, oh, great, that's off my to-do list. These are called dark patterns.
这就是为什么他们总是寻找最火的新晋名人来代言，总是寻找那种所谓的“抓马”时刻或大型品牌活动，以尽可能多地吸引人们对产品的关注。没有这些，潮流就什么也不是。品牌提升我们购买微趋势欲望的另一个手段是，让购物过程变得非常紧张，从而促使我们下单。基本上，他们制造出一种紧迫感，让你觉得产品快卖光了，或者促销活动即将结束，这样我们就会快速购买，并获得一种“太好了，这事儿终于从待办事项里划掉了”的解脱感。这些被称为“黑暗模式”。
A 2019 study from Princeton actually cataloged some of these dark economic patterns in retail shopping. and here are some of the most common ones that you are going to see, especially like in fast fashion brands or really with any brand. So the first one is like urgency pushing. So if you obviously a countdown timer warning you that like a special offer is going to end in 60 seconds unless you that is a tactic. That is trying to stress you out. So you just try and remove the stress in the easiest way possible, which is to buy. There's also something called confirm shaming. So they'll offer you a discount and then you have to be like, no thanks. I'd rather pay full price if you decline. Like if you decline to sign up for like their email chain, which, you know,
普林斯顿大学2019年的一项研究记录了零售购物中的一些黑暗经济模式。以下是你最常看到的几种，尤其是在快时尚品牌或任何品牌中。第一种是“紧迫感推销”。如果你看到一个倒计时器警告你，如果不在60秒内下单，特别优惠就会结束，这就是一种策略。它试图让你感到压力，这样你就会试图用最简单的方式消除压力，那就是购买。还有一种叫“确认羞辱”。他们会提供折扣，如果你拒绝，你必须点击类似“不，谢谢，我宁愿原价购买”的选项。比如如果你拒绝注册他们的邮件列表，你知道的，
inevitably makes you feel like, God, I've just lost money. I've lost money. But they want access to you. They know that if they can get you to sign up for their email chain, like they're going to make more money off of you, even if it means giving you a discount. And there's also these social proof tactics as well that we're seeing more often, which is like, Gemma from Australia just bought this purchase. Tom from America just saved a million dollars on this item using this discount code. Like those people aren't real, but this stresses you out. It gives you this social sense that like everybody else is in on this. Everybody else is doing this. And when we're stressed out, our prefrontal cortex is impeded. Our prefrontal cortex is responsible for rational decision
这不可避免地让你觉得，天哪，我刚损失了钱。我损失了钱。但他们想要获取你的信息。他们知道，如果能让你注册邮件列表，即使这意味着给你折扣，他们也能从你身上赚到更多钱。我们还经常看到所谓的“社会认同”策略，比如“来自澳大利亚的杰玛刚刚购买了此商品”、“来自美国的汤姆使用此折扣码节省了一百万美元”。这些人并不是真实的，但这会让你感到压力。它给你一种社会认同感，觉得其他人都在参与，其他人都在这么做。当我们感到压力时，我们的前额叶皮层会受到抑制。前额叶皮层负责理性决策，
making. So when it's not able to send out those clarifying messages, emotion just takes over. And again, that lovely dopamine hit comes in to save the day. The company's social media has stressed you out, making you think that you're not going to be accepted. You're going to lose money. You're going to lose something if you don't buy it. So if you buy it, you get the relief. Over time, though, we know this. Like, it takes more. and more for you to receive the same level of pleasure from that dopamine or from that reward of buying something than it did before. That's why it's not just like the one t-shirt that you need. It's the t-shirt and the sweater and the sweater and the jeans. You know, it gets, you need
所以当它无法发出那些理性的信号时，情绪就会占据主导地位。再一次，那种美妙的多巴胺冲击来拯救局面了。公司的社交媒体让你感到压力，让你觉得如果不买，你就不会被接纳，你会损失金钱，你会失去某些东西。所以如果你买了，你就得到了解脱。然而，随着时间的推移，我们知道，你需要越来越多的多巴胺或购买奖励才能获得同样的快感。这就是为什么你需要的不仅仅是一件T恤，而是T恤、毛衣、毛衣和牛仔裤。你知道，你需要
more and more to keep yourself satisfied. And that is why we are constantly wired to want more. Because more is good, right? That's what our brain thinks. More is good. That it's like the basis, the most primary basis of what we call hedonism or our reward system. It is our default. It is our default to want to collect and receive and buy more because back in the day when resources were scarce, that is how we survived. We survived by securing more for ourselves and securing more for our tribe. That's very scientific, lots of information being thrown at you there. How do we apply this to us in our 20s specifically?
越来越多才能让自己满足。这就是为什么我们天生就渴望更多。因为更多就是好，对吧？我们的大脑就是这么想的。更多就是好。这就像我们所说的享乐主义或奖励系统的最基本基础。我们默认想要收集、获取和购买更多，因为在资源匮乏的过去，这就是我们生存的方式。我们通过为自己和部落争取更多资源来生存。这很科学，这里塞给了你很多信息。我们如何将其具体应用到我们20多岁的生活中呢？
here is how we apply it. Our 20s particularly are just chaotic. There's a lot going on. We all understand that. There's always like a fire that needs to be put out. And a big thing that's on fire is our sense of self, right? We don't really know who we are yet, even if we think we do. Microtrends, why they are so appealing during this decade, is because they provide a psychological sense of security, or safety through which we can reaffirm our identity. So essentially what I'm saying is that when you don't know who you are, when your boyfriend's broken up with you, when you don't really know what your dream job is, aligning yourself to what's in and hot and cool gives you a real confidence boost and provides you with a sense of like, well, at least I belong. At least I'm in the no. I really like the way that Terry Wu says it. He's a neuroscientist. He's an author. He runs the organization. why the brain follows. And he says the human brain is not a thinking machine that feels. It is a feeling machine that thinks. Humans have this innate desire. And again, whether you are in
应用方法如下。我们20多岁的时候特别混乱。事情很多。我们都明白这一点。总有火需要去灭。而其中一个正在燃烧的大问题是我们的自我意识，对吧？我们还不太清楚自己是谁，即使我们自以为很清楚。微趋势之所以在这个十年里如此吸引人，是因为它们提供了一种心理上的安全感，通过这种安全感我们可以重申自己的身份。所以本质上我想说的是，当你不知道自己是谁，当你的男朋友和你分手，当你不知道自己梦想的工作是什么时，让自己与当下流行、热门和酷的东西保持一致，会给你带来真正的自信，并提供一种“至少我属于这里，至少我了解情况”的感觉。我真的很喜欢神经科学家、作家、组织“大脑为何追随”的创始人特里·吴的说法。他说，人类大脑不是一个会思考的机器，而是一个会思考的感受机器。人类有一种天生的欲望，无论你是否在
your 20s or not, this innate desire to seize a sense of control. And if clothes, shopping, buying, gives you that, it is very hard to resist, especially during a period where you are already primed to feel chaotic and unsure, you know, it's only natural that shopping can become a coping mechanism. It can actually become an emotional regulator. We talked about this in our psychology of personal style episode. Remember that primal feeling we were talking about, like the desire to gather, collect, store, that kind of thing. That is what's going on here. We're literally like little chipmunks. We're these little squirrels, there's little chipmunks who want to gain more for ourselves and feel confident that we're going to have enough to survive the winter, that we're going to have
20多岁，这种天生的欲望就是抓住一种控制感。如果衣服、购物、购买能给你带来这种感觉，那就很难抗拒，尤其是在你本来就容易感到混乱和不确定的时候。你知道，购物成为一种应对机制是很自然的。它实际上可以成为一种情绪调节器。我们在“个人风格心理学”那一集中讨论过这个问题。还记得我们谈论的那种原始感觉吗？比如收集、储存的欲望，就是这么回事。我们简直就像小花栗鼠。我们是这些小松鼠，这些小花栗鼠，想要为自己获得更多，并确信我们有足够的储备来度过冬天，确信我们有
enough in our tank to feel confident, to feel secure, to feel safe, physically or emotionally. It's literally the same reason why, I don't know if you guys remember this. Of course you do. Like during COVID, everybody was buying toilet paper. Nobody needed that much toilet paper. This was a proxy for a sense of security and a sense of certainty. At this stage, you may be thinking like, okay, Gemma, so what? What is so bad about finding relief and joy through clothes and fashion and style during a really hard time for myself. Or like, what's so wrong with just experimenting? You know, why can't I just look good?
足够的能量来感到自信、感到安全，无论是身体上还是情感上。这和你们是否记得这件事的原因完全一样。当然你们记得。比如在新冠疫情期间，每个人都在抢购卫生纸。没人需要那么多卫生纸。这是一种安全感和确定性的替代品。在这个阶段，你可能会想，好吧，杰玛，那又怎样？在一个非常艰难的时期，通过衣服、时尚和风格来寻找解脱和快乐有什么不好呢？或者，仅仅是尝试一下有什么错呢？你知道，为什么我不能看起来很棒？
Why can't I just follow trends? Because, you know, what's so wrong with wanting to fit in? Honestly, in many ways, nothing. I have to agree with you. Like, probably nothing. However, what is important to know is that microtrens offer a false sense of hope. caring about clothes and feeling emotionally driven towards a trend that is not sustainable, like those are different things.
为什么我不能追随潮流？因为，你知道，想要融入群体有什么错呢？老实说，在很多方面，确实没什么错。我必须同意你的观点。可能真的没什么错。然而，重要的是要知道，微趋势提供了一种虚假的希望。关心衣服和在情感上被一种不可持续的潮流所驱动，这是两码事。
It's basically like I think micro trends are like a bad relationship that keep you hooked on potential. They basically give you the sense that like just one more, one more day, one more purchase and everything will finally be okay. He'll finally love me back. I'll finally feel good about myself. They give you the sense that there is always a newer, better version of you out there. They give you the hope that if I buy into this trend, I will finally feel like myself.
基本上，我认为微趋势就像一段糟糕的关系，让你沉迷于潜力。它们基本上给你一种感觉，好像只要再多一件，再多买一次，一切都会好起来。他最终会爱上我。我最终会对自己感觉良好。它们让你觉得外面总有一个更新、更好的版本在等着你。它们给你希望，如果你追随这个潮流，你最终会感觉像真正的自己。
There is this destination that I will arrive at, I will arrive at in which I will finally be happy and in which I finally will belong and it is behind this next purchase. This has a name. It's aspirational buying. Essentially, it's aspirational thinking. It's fantasy thinking like in a relationship that makes us believe that purchases clothes, micro-trans, whatever, can fill an emotional hole in your life if you just buy enough. This is obviously not true because, again, a few months later, a few days later, the trend changes.
有一个目的地我会到达，在那里我最终会快乐，最终会找到归属感，而它就在下一次购买之后。这有个名字，叫“抱负性购买”。本质上，这是抱负性思维。这就像一段关系中的幻想思维，让我们相信，如果买得足够多，购买衣服、微趋势或其他任何东西就能填补你生活中的情感空洞。这显然是不真实的，因为几个月后，几天后，潮流又变了。
And the thing that we have staked our identity on suddenly becomes shaky again. And the new thing is in. Strawberry Girl, Tomato Woman, Mob husband, soft boy. it's not relevant anymore. So you're forced to go back to the drawing board. In an age where the drawing board is already very, very messy and a lot of us don't have the money to keep changing our identity every single season. So again, it's not that like caring about clothes is bad. It's just that this this pathway to caring about clothes is going to probably leave you feeling really anxious. It's also going to cost you a lot of money like I just mentioned. One British study from last year
而我们寄托身份的东西突然又变得摇摇欲坠。新的东西又流行起来了。草莓女孩、番茄女人、黑帮教父、软萌男孩，它不再相关了。所以你被迫回到原点。在一个原点已经非常非常混乱的时代，我们很多人没有钱每个季节都改变自己的身份。所以，再次强调，关心衣服并不是坏事。只是这种关心衣服的途径可能会让你感到非常焦虑。正如我刚才提到的，这也会花费你很多钱。去年的一项英国研究
estimated that it could cost you $250 a month on the low end of things to have a shopping addiction, to be attached to trends. And again, the less stable your identity is the younger you are, the more you are likely to spend if that is available to you. The more that you want to spend. I'm also of the firm belief, you know, buy it nice, buy it twice. And I just think that truly sitting down and intentionally choosing your style archetypes, labeling your style. Yeah, even if that changes over the years, does save you probably a lot of time. It does save you a lot of money. It saves you closet space and it saves you confusion about how you present and who you are right now.
估计，如果你有购物成瘾，沉迷于潮流，每个月至少要花费250美元。同样，你的身份越不稳定，你越年轻，如果条件允许，你花钱的可能性就越大。你越想花钱。我也坚定地相信“买好的，买一次就好”。我真的认为，真正坐下来，有意识地选择你的风格原型，给你的风格贴上标签，即使这些标签多年后会改变，确实能为你节省很多时间。它确实能为你省钱，节省衣橱空间，并消除你对自己如何呈现以及自己是谁的困惑。
And it seems like a lot more people are agreeing with that. That being intentional about clothes is the way to go. A lot of people are actually saying I was reading all these articles online that there is a very obvious decline in microch trends happening right now. Why is that? We're going to talk about that. And so much more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
似乎有更多人同意这一点。有意识地对待衣服才是正道。很多人实际上在说，我在网上读到所有这些文章，现在微趋势正在明显衰退。为什么会这样？我们将在短暂休息后讨论这个问题以及更多内容。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家交谈，深入探讨主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是致炎的。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app,
我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序上搜索“TWO%”，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek.
Apple Podcasts，或者任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。
And I'm Alex English. episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。说清楚，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学习》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Paul. part. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really,
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞恩、保罗。部分。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，但我们还在追逐，不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同程度的信任。我希望你真的，
be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023,
做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《艰难学习》并立即收听。2023年，
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once.
前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你在这个特定的测试中作假了两次，对吧？我作假了一次。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈指控被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。男人应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prices. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
第一条规则，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会付出愚蠢的代价。第二条规则，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎不在乎，所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。
Okay, again, I've been going on and on about the psychology of microtrends and how they're bad for the environment, how they're bad for your bank account. And it turns out, microtrends are currently dying in very slow death. people are becoming more environmentally conscious, waste conscious. People are also kind of learning to, we've learned to anticipate the trend cycle that we've all seen. And we've kind of learned that they're not going to last very long. So more and more of us are riding out the wave of certain trends. I recently read an interesting Vogue article called Micro Trends Are Dead, Long Live the Vibe. And it talks about how online fashion discourse is changing.
好的，再次强调，我一直在喋喋不休地谈论微趋势的心理学，它们对环境有多糟糕，对你的银行账户有多糟糕。事实证明，微趋势目前正在经历一场非常缓慢的死亡。人们变得更加环保，更有浪费意识。人们也开始学会了，我们已经学会了预测我们都见过的潮流周期。我们已经意识到它们不会持续太久。所以我们越来越多的人正在度过某些潮流的浪潮。我最近读了一篇有趣的《Vogue》文章，标题是《微趋势已死，氛围万岁》。它谈到了在线时尚话语是如何在
in front of our very eyes because being trendy is no longer cool, being individual is. Personal expression, being anti-trend, that is emerging as a counterweight to the algorithm-driven micro-trend, online environment that we've been subjected to. People are tired of having to change who they are every five months to fit in with what other people are doing. People now want something, an aura, a vibe that trends cannot capture because it is so organic and natural, it cannot be repeated, just like our individuality and our identity in itself. I think it's also just because out, like, we're smart, right? Especially people in their 20s, but everybody, like humans are smart. They naturally notice patterns. And I think we've noticed the pattern of the micro trend enough now
我们眼前改变的，因为赶时髦不再酷了，个性化才是。个人表达，反潮流，正在作为一种平衡力量出现，对抗我们一直遭受的算法驱动的微趋势在线环境。人们厌倦了每五个月改变一次自己，以适应别人的做法。人们现在想要某种东西，一种光环，一种潮流无法捕捉的氛围，因为它如此有机和自然，无法被复制，就像我们的个性和身份本身一样。我认为这也是因为，我们很聪明，对吧？尤其是20多岁的人，但每个人都是，人类很聪明。他们自然会注意到模式。我想我们现在已经足够注意到微趋势的模式了，
to become suspicious of it and to recognize also when they're just clever marketing. being stunts. For example, I don't know if you guys remember this, I feel like this has come up a lot in this episode, the Mobwife Microtrend on TikTok, like all these people were accusing it of being an industry plant to tie to the re-release of the Sopranos in 2024. Like that's how people, like that's how companies and brands make things relevant. They tie it to a micro trend. In another article about this titled, Are Microtrends over? The authors of this article basically pointed to the fact that microtrendes, what really gave them an edge was the pandemic and was when everybody was at home and everybody lacked real life experiences. So things like were
以至于对它产生怀疑，并能识别出它们何时只是聪明的营销噱头。例如，我不知道你们是否记得，我觉得这一集里提到了很多次，TikTok上的“黑帮教父妻子”微趋势，所有人都指责它是为了配合2024年《黑道家族》重映而植入的行业营销。这就是公司和品牌让事物变得相关的方式。他们将其与微趋势联系起来。在另一篇关于此的文章《微趋势结束了吗？》中，作者指出，微趋势之所以有优势，是因为疫情，当时每个人都在家，缺乏现实生活体验。所以事情
transmitted very quickly online, trends flowed very quickly online. But now people are really leaning more towards being out and about. They are trying to consume less of less content and less of their identity online. And so they're no longer as relevant. Like it's just basically like we've recovered from the pandemic. The way that information spreads is different and micro trends aren't cool anymore because people are moving back to dressing for their real lives and dressing in a way that is unique and dressing in a way that doesn't signal being chronically online. because being chronically online in itself was a trend and it's now kind of going out of style. In other words, again, it pays to be individual.
在网上迅速传播，潮流在网上流动得非常快。但现在人们更倾向于走出去。他们试图减少在线内容和在线身份的消费。所以它们不再那么相关了。就像我们从疫情中恢复过来一样。信息传播的方式不同了，微趋势不再酷了，因为人们正在回归为真实生活穿衣，以独特的方式穿衣，以一种不显示“长期在线”的方式穿衣。因为“长期在线”本身就是一种潮流，现在有点过时了。换句话说，再次强调，有个性是有回报的。
It pays to have personal style. Having something that no one else can replicate is the trend. So my final thoughts on this actually are not my thoughts. They come from this fashion journalist called Ashanti Austin, who essentially says that this shift away from microtrends and to awards vibes. The reason it's happening is because a vibe doesn't require explicit markers. A vibe can encompass everything from culture to music, food, hobbies, history, background, all these things that cannot be copied. And considering that trends emerge in the first place for
拥有个人风格是有回报的。拥有别人无法复制的东西才是潮流。所以我对此的最终想法其实不是我的想法。它们来自一位名叫阿桑蒂·奥斯汀的时尚记者，她本质上说，这种从微趋势向氛围的转变。之所以发生，是因为氛围不需要明确的标记。氛围可以涵盖从文化到音乐、食物、爱好、历史、背景的所有东西，所有这些都无法被复制。考虑到潮流最初是为了
self-expression and for individualism, why go the micro-trend route? what she basically says, and not to power phrase her words, but what I got from some of her writing is like, essentially, it's cliche. And it's not just cliche, but like, it is a form of rebellion to be like, I can see what you're trying to sell me. And I don't really care for it. And I don't really want to buy into this anymore. Like, I don't want to spend any more of my money being something that you are telling me is going to make me happy. And then you're going to take the rug out from under my feet, like the next moment. I want to be somebody who is firm in their values, firm in their personal style, and cannot be sold to. So here's a quick rapid fire of what you can do instead when you feel
自我表达和个人主义而出现的，为什么要走微趋势路线呢？她基本上说的是，我不打算转述她的话，但我从她的一些文章中得到的是，本质上，这很陈词滥调。而且不仅仅是陈词滥调，这是一种反叛的形式，就像是说：我能看出你在试图卖给我什么。我并不在乎。我不想再买账了。我不想再花钱去成为你告诉我的那种会让我快乐的人。然后你下一刻又会把地毯从我脚下抽走。我想成为一个价值观坚定、个人风格坚定、不会被推销的人。所以，当你感到
the pool of a micro trend calling. And remember, like genuinely, sometimes things become micro trends, but also we just genuinely loved it beforehand. Or something becomes a micro trend. And to you, it's not a micro trend, right? To you, it is a core part of your. style, it's something that you really love. It's not to say that you can't buy into them. This is just how to be more conscious about it. The biggest thing is if you feel the desire to buy something, set it upon yourself to buy the best version of it, not just the first version of it that you see. I would also say if you are feeling like an emotional impulse to buy something, pause, examine where the emotional motivation is coming from.
微趋势的吸引力时，你可以做些什么，这里有一个快速的建议。记住，有时候事情确实会成为微趋势，但我们之前也确实真心喜欢它。或者某件事成为了微趋势。对你来说，它不是微趋势，对吧？对你来说，它是你风格的核心部分，是你真正喜欢的东西。这并不是说你不能购买它们。这只是关于如何更清醒地对待它。最重要的一点是，如果你有购买某样东西的欲望，请务必购买它的最佳版本，而不是你看到的第一个版本。我还要说，如果你感到一种购买某样东西的情感冲动，请暂停，检查这种情感动机来自哪里。
and give yourself 24, 48 hours for that emotion, that motivational or motivating emotion towards the purchase to settle. What other dopamine avenues are available to you right now? What other ways can you get a sense of relief or happiness? Secondly, consider whether you are buying something because of the item or because of the lifestyle or emotion it is trying to sell you. Learn to recognize when the brand's budget has gone towards marketing and not to good craftsmanship or vice versa. Some of the longest wearing things I own are from brands that do not spend any money on big advertising campaigns or which are from op shops or depop or vinted because, you know, the objective there isn't to sell in great quantities or to sell as much as they can.
给自己24到48小时，让那种对购买的动机情感平息下来。你现在还有什么其他多巴胺渠道可用？还有什么其他方式可以获得解脱或快乐？其次，考虑你是为了物品本身而购买，还是为了它试图向你兜售的生活方式或情感而购买。学会识别品牌预算何时用于营销，而不是良好的工艺，反之亦然。我拥有的一些最耐用的东西来自那些不花钱做大型广告活动的品牌，或者来自二手店、Depop或Vinted，因为你知道，那里的目标不是大量销售或尽可能多地销售。
It's just to sell what they have on hand or what they think is good. There is a reason that the fashion and beauty industry is worth billions and billions of dollars every year. It is because marketers are so smart and they have found every single way to make you part with your money. Basically, if you can understand your identity and social psychology better than they do, you will not be manipulated by them into buying something just to feel like you need to belong. genuinely look at the company, look at what you want to buy, and do a bit of an analysis. How long is this actually going to last? And if I do think it's going to last, isn't it better to buy it quality?
它只是为了卖掉他们手头有的东西，或者他们认为好的东西。时尚和美容行业每年价值数十亿美元是有原因的。这是因为营销人员非常聪明，他们找到了每一种让你掏钱的方法。基本上，如果你能比他们更好地理解你的身份和社会心理学，你就不会被他们操纵，为了归属感而购买东西。真正看看公司，看看你想买什么，做一点分析。这实际上能持续多久？如果我确实认为它能持续，买高质量的不是更好吗？
I would also say keep an ongoing list in your phone of items you want to buy and how much they are. And then at the end of the month, yeah, you can buy them if you still want to, if you still want to, they're still in stock, if they're still on trend. but it would also give you, and it also does give you a really rich informational source for how much you are saving by not buying them. And I think it really, like a $20 purchase, a $50 purchase, a $5 purchase here and there, like you don't think about how much that is. But keeping track of what you want to buy or what you are buying monetarily is going to seriously shock you into how many of these techniques are working on you and whether you want them to work on you any long. Finally, a reminder for when you think, this item is the thing that's going to make me happy.
我还要说，在你的手机里保留一份你想买的物品清单以及它们的价格。然后在月底，是的，如果你仍然想要，如果它们还有库存，如果它们仍然流行，你可以买它们。但这也会给你，也确实给你提供了一个非常丰富的信息来源，让你知道通过不买它们你节省了多少钱。我认为这真的，比如20美元的购买，50美元的购买，这里那里的5美元，你不考虑那是多少钱。但跟踪你想买的东西或你在金钱上购买的东西，会让你严重震惊于这些技巧中有多少正在对你起作用，以及你是否希望它们继续对你起作用。最后，当你认为“这个物品就是让我快乐的东西”时，提醒自己。
This item is the one. I want you to think of the happiest moment in your life. What were you wearing in that moment? And if you've been married, you can't use that example, because obviously wedding dress. But simple moments. What were you wearing? Can you remember that? Did it matter?
这个物品就是那个。我希望你想想你生命中最快乐的时刻。那一刻你穿的是什么？如果你结过婚，你不能用那个例子，因为显然是婚纱。但简单的时刻。你穿的是什么？你能记得吗？它重要吗？
Did it really influence the moment that much? I really don't think it does. obviously clothes are a valuable and like super important part of self-expression. They're an art form, but they are not the be-all and end-all of happiness or social security or joy that you can look for. Like there are so many other alternatives. And at the end of the day, the thing that is going to matter the most to you is money spent on memories, money spent on experiences.
它真的对那一刻影响那么大吗？我真的不认为有。显然，衣服是自我表达中有价值且超级重要的一部分。它们是一种艺术形式，但它们不是你所能寻找的快乐、社会保障或喜悦的全部。还有很多其他选择。归根结底，对你来说最重要的是花在回忆上的钱，花在体验上的钱。
and like the memories that will form regardless of what you're wearing and regardless of whether you were trending or wearing the new it thing or not. So that is the end of this very preachy episode. Again, goes without saying you can do whatever you want really at the end of the day. Like you have autonomy and agency and if you like something, yeah, and you have the money. You can buy it if you would like. But I think this episode is just about giving you more of a conscious look into how brands and how algorithms are like directed to control you using your psychology and how they
以及无论你穿什么，无论你是否在追逐潮流或穿着新的流行单品，都会形成的回忆。所以这就是这一集非常说教的内容的结尾。再次强调，不用说，归根结底你可以做任何你想做的事。你有自主权和代理权，如果你喜欢某样东西，是的，你有钱。如果你愿意，你可以买它。但我认为这一集只是为了让你更清醒地了解品牌和算法是如何被引导来利用你的心理来控制你的，以及它们
deeply want you to part with your money and are in many ways like manipulating your neuroscience and your emotions and your cognition to get you to do so so yeah i found it super interesting to research this episode and to look into all these different processes i also want to thank our researcher lucy davidson for her help with this episode and for all the research and writing that she did, she is amazing. If you have made it this far, and you're a loyal listener, and you were listening on Spotify, I should say, leave a comment down below. What do you think is like the biggest micro trend of the moment? What do you think is the thing that you are looking around being like,
非常渴望你掏钱，并且在许多方面像是在操纵你的神经科学、情绪和认知来让你这样做。所以是的，我发现研究这一集并深入了解所有这些不同的过程非常有趣。我也要感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森对这一集的帮助，以及她所做的所有研究和写作，她太棒了。如果你已经看到了这里，并且你是一位忠实的听众，而且你是在Spotify上收听的，我应该说，在下面留下评论。你认为当下最大的微趋势是什么？你认为你环顾四周觉得，
that is not going to last. That is going to be kaput in like a few weeks. I will go first. I think it's the deer print. I think we're going to see the death of deer print. And I also think we're going to see the death of like baby pink activeware. I don't know. Maybe not. You can disagree with me in the comments. But as always, make sure that you are following along wherever you are listening.
那不会持续太久。那会在几周内完蛋。我先来。我认为是鹿纹。我认为我们将看到鹿纹的消亡。我也认为我们将看到婴儿粉色运动服的消亡。我不知道。也许不是。你可以在评论中不同意我。但一如既往，确保你在收听的地方关注我们。
If this episode resonated with you, if you enjoyed it, please leave us a five-star review. Maybe send it to a friend who you think would also be interested so you guys can have a chat about it. But until next time, thank you again for joining us. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Rethink the next micro trend you see come across your feed. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
如果这一集引起了你的共鸣，如果你喜欢它，请给我们留下五星好评。也许把它发给一个你认为也会感兴趣的朋友，这样你们就可以聊聊了。但直到下次，再次感谢你的加入。保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。重新思考你在动态中看到的下一个微趋势。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier more fulfilled healthier person listen to 2% that's t w0% on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts on the look back at it podcast from 1979 that was a big moment for me 84's big to me i'm sam j and i'm alex english each episode we pick a here unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends fellow comedians and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。在《回顾过去》播客中，从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·杰克，我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起幸存下来的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是非常疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional. who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
那是非常疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《艰难学习》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Grega lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
你在这个特定的测试中作假了两次，埃伦女士，对吧？我作假了一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all day. the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友。收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。这是一个iHeart播客。
Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证人类。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。